este vídeo ha sido posible gracias al
surf shark vpn luego os doy más detalles
pero antes vamos con nuestra historia de
hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
tailandia es un país capaz de atraer al
mismo tiempo a monjes budistas viajeros
en busca de aventuras y a los de resacón
en tailandia hay muchas razones por las
que todos hemos oído hablar de fiestas
increíbles en bangkok y no en otros
sitios como brunei o malasia son razones
como esta
[Música]
tailandia líder a asia legalizar la
marihuana médica
tailandia podría convertirse en el
primer país del sudeste asiático en
legalizar las uniones del mismo sexo o
si playas marihuana derechos lgtb
tailandia parece algo así como
california pero en versión asiática
monárquica y un poco más barata sin
embargo en esta semana hasta islandia
está saliendo en los medios por noticias
como esta
[Música]
las protestas en tailandia están
haciendo historia por primera vez en
décadas la gente están desafiando
abiertamente la autoridad del monarca
para que os hagáis una idea desde julio
de este año 2020 miles de tailandeses se
han echado a las calles para pedir un
cambio total de régimen cambiar la
constitución reformar la monarquía y
celebrar elecciones libres como dato
curioso en lugar de levantar el puño o
la mano los tailandeses levantan estos
tres dedos y si esto este saludo está
sacando directamente de las películas de
los juegos del hambre pero porque usan
este saludo os lo cuento a lo largo de
este vídeo pero por ahora volvamos con
nuestra historia porque creedme a los
tailandeses no les faltan razones para
protestar hablamos de uno de los países
más autoritarios del mundo
el sistema político de tailandia es un
híbrido entre monarquía absoluta
teocracia y dictadura militar de hecho
la casa real tailandesa es la más rica
del mundo superando incluso a las
petromonarquías y tiene muchísimo más
poder que cualquier monarquía europea y
ya sé lo que me vais a decir venga ya
fonseca si son tan autoritarios como es
posible que tengan tantísimo turismo
como es posible que haya tantos nómadas
digitales que se hayan ido a vivir aquí
ciudades como bangkok o chapman son
destinos de moda para los llamados
nómadas digitales es decir gente que
trabaja en internet que puede vivir en
cualquier otro lugar del mundo pero que
elige tailandia y lo cierto es que
tailandia puede ser un país fantástico
para un occidental ahora bien si eres
tailandés es muy probable que no pienses
lo mismo
tailandés pasará un largo tiempo en la
cárcel por hacer un comentario
sarcástico sobre el perro del rey para
que os hagáis una idea tailandia tiene
la cuarta población carcelaria más
grande del mundo sólo por delante de
turno están cuba y por supuesto los eeuu
y aquí hago un paréntesis si eeuu tiene
la población carcelaria más grande del
mundo pero de eso ya hablamos en este
otro vídeo lo cierto es que comparado
con las cárceles tailandesas las de eeuu
parecen un hotel de 5 estrellas y como
vamos a ver más adelante es muy fácil
acabar en una cárcel tailandesa y todo
eso explica protestas tan intensas como
esta
estas de tailandia miles de personas se
reúnen por tercer día consecutivo pese a
las prohibiciones del gobierno sin
embargo si estáis familiarizados con la
política tailandesa es probable que
estas noticias nos llamen mucho la
atención en anteriores vídeos de visual
política os hemos hablado de cómo
funciona el sistema político en este
lugar y si verá algo caracteriza
tailandia son los cambios de régimen
para que os hagáis una idea desde 1932
tailandia ha sufrido una media de un
golpe de estado cada cuatro años habéis
oído bien los cambios de régimen son
algo tan habitual en este país que ni
siquiera son de noticias sin embargo
estas protestas son especiales y puede
que esta vez sí veamos un cambio real de
todo el sistema político en tailandia
entonces porque la historia de hoy tiene
de todo economía dioses vivientes y sexo
mucho sexo y hasta pilinguis
así que la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos
es por qué estas protestas en tailandia
son tan importantes que piden
exactamente a los manifestantes cuál es
el problema real en tailandia y por qué
han adoptado el saludo de los juegos del
hambre como forma de protesta hoy vamos
a responder a estas preguntas pero antes
antes vamos a hablar de internet si
vives en un país como tailandia es
posible que ni siquiera podáis ver
vídeos como este internet es como el
salvaje oeste no solo estamos a merced
de hackers sino también de gobiernos que
no se llevan demasiado bien con la
libertad de expresión y los derechos
humanos pero hay una forma de protegerse
de todos estos problemas y eso es
navegando a través de una vpn una vpn
como subsal
[Música]
césar que es una vpn fantástica por
muchas razones seguro que todos habéis
caído alguna vez en nuestras páginas web
de spam que intentan estafar nos con
popa a este tipo de prácticas se les
llama phishing pues bien su usar tiene
una herramienta que se llama clean web
que bloquea todos estos por fax y todos
estos enlaces que pueden ser un
auténtico peligro pero no sólo eso con
una única cuenta de surf shark podéis
registrar todos los dispositivos que
queráis el móvil la tablet el portátil
no hay ningún límite de dispositivo
[Música]
siempre tenemos una oferta muy especial
para todos vosotros que seguís visual
política básicamente si utilizáis el
código político terminado
tendréis un 83% de descuento más tres
meses extra totalmente gratis es más
podéis probar su usar durante los
primeros 30 días sin ningún compromiso
en la descripción
os dejo los detalles y ahora sí vamos a
ver un poco de historia
e
un mandato divino no es la primera vez
que hablamos de una teocracia visual
política en muchos otros países como
arabia saudita o la república islámica
de irán la religión y la política van de
la mano sin embargo el caso de tailandia
va mucho más allá
[Música]
en este caso el rey está considerado
directamente como el avatar de dios en
la tierra así tal cual como lo es de
hecho al actual rey de tailandia se le
conoce como rama décimo antes de él
estaba rama noveno y así hasta rama
primera rama es el nombre que se les da
tras la coronación y es literalmente el
nombre tailandés de la diosa abismo
para que os hagáis una idea hasta el año
1932 tailandia en una monarquía absoluta
desde entonces hay una constitución que
limita el poder del rey pero aún así el
monarca sigue teniendo muchísimo poder a
fin de cuentas es un dios
ahora bien por muy divinos que sean los
reyes tailandeses se mueven por pasiones
muy humanas el rey rama noveno también
conocido por su nombre de pila
brumby ball fue coronado cuando tenía 23
añitos después de que alguien asesinar a
a su hermano mayor rama octavo todo esto
ya suena disparatado de por sí pero
esperad porque todavía no habéis visto
nada
[Música]
lo lógico sería pensar que el rey rama
noveno también conocido como señor sobre
nuestras cabezas o señor de la vida
hubiera nacido en tailandia verdad a fin
de cuentas es el rey de este país pues
craso error el bueno de rama noveno
nació en cambridge massachusetts después
de su familia se mudó a suiza donde
estudió en la universidad de lausanne
que imaginaos electro este hombre
viviendo en occidente con amigos suizos
que le preguntan oye tú que vas a ser de
mayor
yo cuyos que me voy a dedicar a ser una
deidad en tailandia vamos de traca es
más tras tantos años educandos en
occidente rama noveno adquirió ciertos
hábitos concretamente aprendí a tocar
jazz
y de hecho llegó a componer sus propias
piezas
[Música]
pero volvamos con nuestra historia como
os podéis imaginar si los tailandeses
consideran que su rey es un dios
cualquier ofensa contra la monarquía
está considerada como una blasfemia o
como ellos lo llaman crímenes de lesa
majestad y atentos porque no se trata de
un tema menor las leyes de lesa majestad
en tailandia son conocidas por ser muy
genéricas es decir que no está del todo
claro en lo que cuenta y lo que no
cuenta como blasfemia lo único que
tienen claro son las penas que pueden
llegar hasta los 15 años de cárcel y hay
casos totalmente disparatados
todos los casos que os voy a dar son
ejemplos reales atentos a cosas por las
que puedes ir a la cárcel en tailandia
traducir una biografía no autorizada del
rey dos años de cárcel insultar al perro
del rey en internet 37 años de cárcel
echar pintura negra sobre un retrato del
rey diez años de cárcel pero esperad un
momento porque todavía no hemos hablado
de los delitos de sedición atentos a la
lista de cosas que te pueden llevar a la
cárcel en tailandia llevar una camisa
roja comer sándwiches como forma de
protesta política o mostrar a un papel
que diga
ar papeles no es un crimen repito todo
esto son casos reales que han llevado a
gente a la cárcel y por supuesto entre
todos estos terribles crímenes de
sedición está hacer el saludo que
aparece en la película los juegos del
hambre' enseñando estos tres dedos
por lo visto en el año 2014 unos
manifestantes lo empezaron a utilizar el
gesto caló entre los jóvenes y desde
entonces levantar los tres dedos así es
un delito en tailandia por el que te
pueden llevar a la cara
[Música]
a estas alturas seguro que muchos
estaréis preguntando cómo es posible que
los tailandeses no se hayan levantado
antes contra su rey la monarquía en
tailandia existe desde hace siglos
porque es ahora cuando por fin empiezan
a protestar pues lo cierto es que hasta
hace unos pocos años el rey de tailandia
era una figura realmente popular
y
para que os hagáis una idea más de 12
millones de personas asistieron al
funeral del rey bhumibol para despedirse
y pensar que tailandia tiene 64 millones
de habitantes es decir que el 25 de
octubre de 2017 uno de cada seis
tailandeses mejor lo que fuera que
estuviera haciendo para irse al gran
palacio de bangkok a decir adiós a su
rey
incluso en los cines antes de ir a ver
la película los tailandeses tienen que
ponerse de pie y escuchar el himno real
de tailandia y ya sé lo que me vais a
decir si la monarquía es tan popular en
este país como es posible que tengan
tantos golpes de estado pues ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
[Música]
una dictadura cada cuatro años una de
las principales ventajas de la
democracia es que permite el cambio de
poder sin derramamiento de sangre es
decir en lugar de gastar dinero en armas
para una guerra civil los candidatos se
lo gastan en maquinaria electoral pues
bien a falta de democracia en tailandia
pasa lo contrario los candidatos se
gastan en armas lo que en otros sitios
se gastan en anuncios
conclusión tailandia ha sufrido 19
golpes de estado desde el año 1932 y de
esos 19 golpes 12 tuvieron éxito y otros
7 no y lo cierto es que todos estos
golpes de estado cumplen un patrón muy
parecido una facción del ejército
organiza el golpe de estado y después es
el rey quien decide si lo quiere apoyar
o no el que pierde se tiene que ir al
exilio y el ganador se convierte en
dictador del país durante unos años
normalmente unos cuatro vamos que son
como las elecciones pero solo vota una
persona el rey
[Música]
algunos de estos golpes de estado han
sido realmente violentos por ejemplo en
el año 1973 varios estudiantes se
manifestaron contra el gobierno militar
77 estudiantes fueron masacrados y 850
terminaron gravemente heridos en una
protesta
esa misma noche el rey anunció que el
gobierno militar tenía que dimitir unos
años más tarde el dictador está non
crítica chorne estaba en el exilio sin
embargo otros golpes de estados son
mucho más pacíficos por ejemplo el del
año 1957 duró solamente unas pocas horas
en este caso fue el comandante sarita
nara quien mandó a sus tropas leales a
tomar los objetivos militares más
importantes la apoyaba a un importante
grupo de civiles que estaban protestando
en las calles horas más tarde este buen
señor se convertía en el nuevo primer
ministro de tailandia el anterior por
supuesto se marchó exiliado europa y
volvió al país seis años más tarde para
que pues para volver a ser el primer
ministro vamos que en este país las
dictaduras militares vienen y van pero
hay algo que se mantiene la monarquía
y os preguntaréis pero cómo es posible
que la gente apoye este sistema una
respuesta bastante convincente es la
economía con o sin falta de libertad
tailandia es uno de los países más ricos
de la zona por hacer la comparación el
pib per cápita en paridad con el poder
adquisitivo está en 18.000 dólares el de
filipinas que está cerca está en menos
de la mitad 8500 dólares y el de china
en 17.000 es decir que mientras en china
muchas zonas todavía no tienen ni
siquiera hospitales modernos tailandia
tiene sanidad pública en todo el país
para que os hagáis una idea cuando sus
vecinos vietnamitas estaban saliendo de
las hambrunas a finales de los años 90
los tailandeses tenían ya las fábricas
de coches o de discos duros más grandes
de toda la región además son toda una
potencia turística en 2017 eran el
décimo país más visitado del mundo muy
por encima de república dominicana o
brasil
[Música]
y ya sé lo que es estar 'aces'
preguntando muchos cómo es posible que
tailandia tengo una economía tan
próspera teniendo un sistema político
tan salvaje pues principalmente por dos
razones su divisa el bap es una de las
más estables del mundo y 2 tailandia
siempre ha tenido muy buenas relaciones
con occidente principalmente con jabón y
diréis pero y qué ha cambiado
exactamente ahora porque ahora estas
protestas son tan importantes pues
atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la trampa de los ingresos medios en
octubre de 2016 el queridísimo y
amadísimo líder el rey rama noveno murió
en el hospital con 88 años
en un país que depende tanto de una
única persona la muerte del rey podría
ser una bomba de relojería pero en este
caso el país estaba a punto de aprobar
una nueva constitución mediante un
referéndum como os podéis imaginar este
referéndum no tenía ninguna garantía y
el ejército prácticamente decía lo que
los ciudadanos tenían que votar porque
tailandia es así pero en este caso a
falta de un rey la junta militar puso un
senado a su humanidad eso es cierto y
anunció elecciones libres o sea todos
los libres que puedan ser en tailandia
es decir que el ejército seguiría
supervisando el proceso pero que al
menos se podrían presentar partidos de
oposición
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y qué pasa cuando de repente permites
que aparezcan partidos políticos de
oposición pues qué sorpresa surgen
nuevos partidos de oposición por primera
vez en décadas el parlamento de
tailandia tuvo un partido de oposición
democrática con una presencia importante
[Música]
los ramos del partido futuro hacia
adelante fundado por el señor tanatorio
juan gran actor juan gran bueno fundado
por el señor antón louro grau que se
trata de una formación que propone un
cambio en la constitución que limite los
poderes del rey garantice elecciones
libres y derechos humanos y en las
elecciones de marzo consiguieron un 18
por ciento de voto lo cual no está nada
mal teniendo en cuenta que hay más de
siete grandes partidos en el parlamento
de hecho futuro adelante quedó como la
tercera fuerza política como os podéis
imaginar el señor anadón chung yong
aunque es uno de los líderes más
influyentes ahora mismo en tailandia
[Música]
cierto que en este país también es
conocido por ser el hijo de uno de los
mayores millonarios del país lejos de
jugar su contra esto refuerza su imagen
porque pudiendo vivir una vida de lujos
y sin preocupaciones ha decidido
arriesgarlo todo por mejorar el país y
creedme lo está arriesgando todo y es un
riesgo real
su partido ha sido prohibido puede ir a
la cárcel pero zarratón your own aunque
jura seguir luchando esta noticia en sí
misma podría suponer el fin del partido
futuro adelante sin embargo hay muchas
cosas que han cambiado en tailandia
la primera es la economía recordáis que
os decía que tailandia era uno de los
países más prósperos de la zona pues es
cierto lo era mientras todos los países
del sudeste asiático crecen a ritmos del
56 7% tailandia apenas pasa del 2% en
economía esto tiene un nombre llamamos
la trampa de los ingresos medios
hay muchos países que sí es cierto
consiguen escapar de la pobreza y llegar
a lo que llamaríamos renta media sin
embargo no consiguen dar el salto para
poder ser un país rico países como
brasil colombia o tailandia parecen
haberse estancado en esta situación pero
no sólo eso si recordáis una de las
principales industrias de tailandia es
el turismo supone más del 12 por ciento
del pib del país y cuál es el sector más
afectado por el coronavirus exacto el
turismo después del turismo otra de las
principales industrias de este país son
los automóviles pues atentos
[Música]
general motors despedirá a todos sus
1500 trabajadores de cadena en tailandia
tras la venta de sus fábricas y no sólo
hablamos de general motors trium los
fabricantes de motos también han cerrado
fábricas en tailandia y otras tantas
amenazan con hacerlo
[Música]
en total la producción de coches en
tailandia ha bajado un 30% en este 2020
y su pib ha caído más de un 12% todo
esto se traduce en miles de personas que
se están yendo al paro sin embargo esto
no es lo único que ha cambiado en este
país recordáis que al principio de este
vídeo os prometí que habría sexo mucho
sexo y hasta pilinguis pues aquí lo
tenéis confinado con 20 concubinas sí
así es como ha pasado el confinamiento
el actual rey de tailandia en una
mansión en alemania con 20 concubinas y
ya sé lo que me dirá alguno pero como
sabes que eran 20 concubinas y si eran
simplemente no sé sus sirvientas o sus
amigas pues lo cierto es que el rey
vajiralongkorn tiene una larga y
conocida relación con las concubinas
el rey playboy nombra a su amante como
la concubina oficial sí señor sí señor
otros reyes en otros países dirían que
sé que tienen una colaboradora o
simplemente una amiga en tailandés
llaman a las cosas por su nombre
concubina oficial tal cual incluso hay
vídeos en wikileaks donde podéis ver
de todo con este ere por supuesto que en
visual político nunca vamos a juzgar la
vida sexual de nadie mientras no rompa
ninguna ley este hombre puede hacer lo
que quiera ahora bien recordad que no
sólo es un rey también es rama de cine
nada menos que un
veréis durante su reinado el anterior
rey rama noveno se había ganado el
respeto de los tailandeses en una
sociedad tan conservadora rama noveno
representaba la rectitud y la disciplina
el hijo es todo lo contrario se ha
divorciado tres veces tiene cuatro hijos
bastardos y ha nombrado a su perro
comandante del ejército del aire por si
todo esto fuera poco el señor rama
décimo ni siquiera viven tailandia en el
año 2016 se compró una mansión en
bavaria al sur de alemania y quiere
reinar tailandia desde ahí
[Música]
de hecho esta fue una de sus condiciones
para aprobar la constitución del 2017
tenían que dejarle reinar desde alemania
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando oye y
si este rey simplemente no quiere reinar
podría ser el caso quiere alejarse de la
política y vivir su propia vida con sus
mansiones y sus concubinas pues la
realidad es todo lo contrario
hace dos semanas el rey de tailandia
emitió un decreto real colocando a dos
unidades del ejército bajo su control
directo en lugar de la jerarquía militar
normal habéis oído bien rama décimo está
dando los pasos para reinstaurar la
monarquía absoluta en tailandia cada vez
tiene un control mayor sobre el ejército
en las elecciones de 2019 prohibió a su
hermana que se presentara como candidata
a primera ministra pero esto no es lo
peor veréis hasta el año 2017 en las
propiedades de la casa real tailandesa
estaban administradas por la oficina de
las propiedades reales una institución
controlada por el ministerio de finanzas
para que os hagáis una idea estas
propiedades eran algo así como una
especie de fondo soberano con
inversiones en empresas locales por
ejemplo uno de los principales
accionistas de uno de los bancos más
grandes de todo el país el siam
commercialbank es la casa real
tailandesa pues bien lo primero que hizo
rama décimo nada más llegó al control
fue hacerse con el control absoluto de
esta oficina se estima que esta
institución controla 40 mil millones de
dólares que ahora están únicamente en
manos del rey pero aquí no termina la
historia además se ha subido el sueldo a
partir de 2021 la casa real tailandesa
cobrará más de 1100 millones de dólares
del gobierno y todo esto desde su
mansión en alemania
más
en otras palabras que tailandia tiene
todos los ingredientes para una revuelta
popular malestar económico una élite
corrupta que ha perdido la confianza de
la mayoría de los ciudadanos y un líder
el señor and young law que capaz de
aglutinar todo este descontento y que
piden estos manifestantes pues sus
principales reclamaciones son acabar con
los crímenes de lesa majestad obligar a
la corona a ser transparente con sus
propiedades y prohibir que el rey puede
instigar golpes de estado pueden parecer
reclamaciones muy moderadas pero
recordad que hablamos del que quizás sea
el país más monárquico del mundo y por
eso es tan increíble que sea ahora
cuando se empiecen a escuchar cosas como
esta
los manifestantes de tailandia piden el
fin de la monarquía durante el
cumpleaños del rey
pensó quien no estamos hablando de una o
dos protestas las manifestaciones en
tailandia empezarán en febrero de 2020 y
después de julio de 2020 mucha más gente
empezó a salir a las calles las plazas y
las universidades hay protestas en todas
las principales ciudades por el momento
no ha habido ningún muerto pero sí
varios intentos por parte del ejército y
la policía de reprimirlas
sin embargo los manifestantes siguen
protestando así que ahora la pregunta es
para vosotros creéis que estas protestas
van a crear un cambio real en tailandia
qué pensáis de la monarquía tailandesa y
de la monarquía en general creéis que es
una institución anticuada o que tal vez
pueda tener cabida en nuestro tiempo
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos a visual
política y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones recordad que también
podéis seguir en nuestro canal hermano
megaproyectos con cada visual polític
donde hablamos de los grandes proyectos
de la humanidad si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]